a house split down the middle there was
panic among residents here in West
Bengal one of India's most popular
state's witnesses say the earth moved
for at least a minute people ran but
there was no escape from the tremor I
felt a strange vibration and thought it
was coming from my body but when I stood
up it shook me and the whole apartment
it was the same outside everything was
moving building all units of he'll die
copy the tremors were felt in New Delhi
as well he had two people fled into the
streets high-rise buildings were
evacuated but damage was minor in the
Indian capital things were much worse in
utter pradesh and especially so in Bihar
India's poorest state which shares a
border with Nepal many of the injured
here were children rescue workers say
falling debris was a major hazard
India has also heeded Nepal's urgent
call for international help it has sent
10 rescue teams and medical supplies to
Katmandu the team also includes medical
and paramedics the team have equipment
such as live detector machines cutters
which can cut steel concrete and wood
India is prepared for earthquake
disasters much more so than its porno
vinader it's a little more important
that help comes quickly now